PAWAN SINHA: There's a
really compelling link
between neuroscience and art.
Neuroscientists want to
understand how the brain works.
What information does
the brain need in order
to recognize things
in the environment?
Artists, they have
essentially distilled
their sensory experience
into the keys that enable
to perceive what to understand.
What it is that they
are trying to depict.
And it's that link that
we hope comes through
in this class for
all of the students.
KRISTINE HOCKER: So
vision is really complex.
And this is something
that I've learned
in previous
neuroscience classes.
But what is really
unique about this class
is that art allows you
to really slow down
the process of your
own visual perception.
And so, when you're
doing hands on work
you really get to experience
yourself seeing the world.
SETH RISKIN: Visual
art in the way that we
practice it is quite specific.
We create with
materials and light.
And we then perceive
our creations
and we learn from that.
So art has the
capacity to go deep
into perceptual experience.
And we work with
the students to gain
consciousness of that process.
SARAH SCHWETTMANN: The
class has two components
that complement one another.
A studio and a seminar.
In the seminar, we cover
our current understanding
of visual neuroscience.
How the brain makes
sense of incoming data.
Then we translate that
scientific understanding
into hands-on practice
in the studio.
Over the course of
the semester, students
start to develop individual
artworks for exhibition.
SETH RISKIN: Each student
decides what area of perception
draws them.
And what they're going to probe
through their own artistic
experimentation.
KRISTINE HOCKER: My
piece shows the viewer
how important visual cues are
for experiencing the world.
So what I wanted to do
was suspend an object
in the Ganzfeld, which is
a space where everything
is the same color and
the same brightness
and make it disappear.
What was striking to me is
how similar total lightness
and total darkness are.
Your brain needs to perceive
things like edges and depth
and shadows to make sense
of what it's seeing.
Otherwise, it's like you're
looking into total darkness.
SETH RISKIN: Art is
a curious method.
We create things
in the world to see
what they have to say about us.
This is the way we
use art in the course.
Not as corroboration
of scientific theory.
But as companion
and at times as lead
to discoveries on the
nature of perception.